[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered I'm Peter labelled
Syria when a pullout well doesn't mean a
pullout also Venezuela how's that regime
change going and the botched story known
as Briggs it and much much more on this
edition of crustal
[Music]
cross knocking some real news I'm joined
by the one in only dmitry babichenko
he's a political analyst with Sputnik
International and in Athens we cross to
Alex Christopher oh he is the director
in writer for the Durant calm or a
gentleman crosstalk rules in effect that
means you can jump in anytime you want
and I always appreciate it
all right Alex let me go to you to you
in Athens here we we have this pullout
down from two thousand to two hundred
now it's four hundred what is the
narrative here what is the reasoning
behind it and why should we believe it's
the pullouts going to happen at all
because the narrative has changed so
many times since December go ahead in
Athens
well we've moved from from a withdrawal
Peter to an occupation and you know
let's be clear this is becoming an
occupation and of course they're using
the pretext of you know protecting the
Kurds and staying in Syria for those
reasons but what it really is is the
neo-cons once again inserting themselves
in transferrin policy and now I won't
even say inserting they are leading
Trump's foreign policy once again you
always have the specter of John Bolton
and Mike Pompeo kind of sitting in the
background as Trump is announcing one of
his major major campaign promises he
campaigned on getting the u.s. out of
all these military entanglements
specifically Syria in 2013 Trump sent
three four maybe even five tweets saying
what is Obama doing in Syria if I was
president I would get out he announced
that he was going to withdraw from 2000
now we've got to 200 troops are going to
stay and we're going to go to 400 and
Peter the question is are we going to go
in three months time to a thousand
troops yeah how long are we going to
stay in Syria is it going to be 10 years
20 years is this gonna be like
Afghanistan are we looking at a 20 year
occupation of the country so no one
really knows at which direction this is
going but one thing's for sure the
neocons are running Trump safari policy
you know team and one of the interesting
things the Kurds have brought up all of
the time but logic would dictate in the
entire history of the conflict would
dictate the
the Damascus government and the Kurds
huddled together and hammer out some
kind of agreement because during the
course of this conflict the Kurds and
the Damascus government have really had
very few direct conflicts here so this
is a ruse here it looks like to me and I
like width Alexander Cristofori said
this is an occupation in search of a
mission and it may have a lot more to do
with pleasing the Israelis and
quote-unquote keeping their eye on the
Iranians and also and I think is very
very important here is to be the
ultimate spoiler in ending this conflict
that never should have happened in the
first place do you know it's absolutely
you're right about almost all of your
points I would say that with the Kurds
the fantastic thing was that when the
United States announced that they are
pulling out of northeastern Syria and
everyone expected the Turks to an taman
beach then suddenly the Kurdish militia
said no no we would prefer the Syrian
government to be there and this was such
a huge blow to the narrative of the
Western press because the narrative in
the European Union and the United States
was that there is nothing worse than the
Assad government the Kurds are going to
be terrified you know all the people in
Syria terrified and then these people
invite the Syrian forces to Miami Beach
but also I'm just putting myself in the
position of someone who reads newspapers
in in Washington and tries to make sense
of it all what does that person read in
The Washington Post George Rogan Trump's
text steps back from the brink of
disaster in Syria
that reminds me you know of the Soviet
joke we were standing on the brink of a
precipice but thank God we made a huge
step forward you know the the latest
news from the New York Times is that
actually they first increase the number
of US troops in Northeast Syria to 3,000
right
and now the Trump is talking about
hundreds of state hundreds how many 20
hundredths that means the whole
contingent really because let me go back
to Athens and Alexei also this this move
and if it's I don't know how stable it
is this decision actually gets air21 off
the hook to resolve the issues in
in lib so again this lack of clarity
coming out of Washington is a barrier to
ending this conflict cuz we are in the
penultimate moment and now it looks like
we're back to square one and how this
conflict is going to end it's
frustrating Russia it's frustrating
around it's frustrating maybe in a
positive way for the Turks here but
maybe that's the whole point isn't it
it's just a churn up this a quagmire
keep it going
we know the Trump administration said
this before the end of last year so it
looks like this plan of churning and
turning this quagmire is actually the
real underlining policy Alex and go
ahead and Athens yeah I think you know
we've said it over and over and it's
really about occupation and to me the
most disheartening part of all of this
Peter is that these are really
self-inflicted wounds that Trump is is
putting onto himself the Trump
administration is putting onto
themselves the the conflict in Syria can
be resolved very very quickly if the US
would just pull out and they would allow
the Kurds to talk to the Syrian
government and that's the key word what
Dimitri said the Syrian government the
internationally recognized legitimate
Syrian government these are who the
Kurds need to be talking with in order
to resolve this conflict once and for
all
but the fact that you're keeping two
hundred and now it's four hundred and in
three months it'll be a thousand and six
months it'll be five thousand the fact
that this is happening is just delaying
the process of bringing peace to Syria
that's the bottom line and it's really
also going to hurt Trump in 2020 he
needs to realize this his constituency
his voters they don't know why the u.s.
is in Syria and they want out of Syria
this is hurting him in the end
okay deemo Alex this used the phrase
self-inflicted wound let's revisit the
Warsaw conference the anti Iran a Warsaw
conference um would you give a scorecard
for our audience winners losers was
anything achieved well it's just amazing
you know these amazing
polish prayers trumpeted that this was a
huge success for the Polish diplomacy
you know the judge postponed at one of
the two biggest polish newspapers wrote
that basically it's like Madrid in 1991
well immediately a lot of people just
laughed at it it in Poland you know
because they noted the difference in
1991 people were talking about peace in
the Middle East about military forces
being kind of
you know creating a safe zone there now
we are talking about war war exactly
about about basically containing Iran
with which in the American modern
language means war right we have
basically the the former New York Mayor
New York City Mayor Giuliani meeting
meeting the representatives over this
organization the mujahedeen a hulk mak
which committed a terrorist act all the
you know during the conference traces of
the messiah president for the left
barack obama took them off the terrorism
yes and and and and you know these
people whatever their purposes maybe
they're lost you but the methods that
they used a terrible you know there were
people killed in Iran and Giuliani after
meeting them says let me quote it
everyone agrees that Iran is the number
one state sponsor of terrorism in the
world that has to tell you something
Iran is a country you can't rely on do
business with you can't trust it okay so
I think you and I and Alex in our
audience knows what country that is and
it's not let me go back to Alex and
Athens here again a self-inflicted wound
here because the highest officials in
the foreign policy leader of the EU
boycotted it they didn't want to have
anything to do with it and also as we've
said previously when Benjamin Netanyahu
got on the plane on his own website page
it was you know this is a paraphrasing
year Conclave for more against Iran well
I think by the time he landed on the in
Warsaw is and they did they had to
change that to conflict okay because
Arab leaders were there
but we didn't we didn't sign up for that
kind of language here I mean it's it it
looks like the administration is just
completely tone-deaf and then this
administration when it comes to Iran
even though it's a continuity of
American foreign policy it's its allies
around the world are not in a lockstep
and this is very frustrating for a
Pompeo for pens and for Bolton go ahead
in Athens yeah this meeting is is a
complete mystery why it even went on I
mean no one can really explain the
purpose of this meeting in this
conference at all low level diplomats
were sent to this conference meanwhile
you had Pompeo and pence the two of the
highest officials from the US government
are sitting there with low-level
diplomats from the EU and other Arab
nations from the beginning until the end
this conference was a complete disaster
you mentioned the tweet by Netanyahu
where he said there's about war with
Iran they had to change that nearly an
hour or two later so this was sitting on
his website and on Twitter where he said
the goal of this conference was for war
with Iran and then you had Mike Pence
giving a speech to everybody there where
he reiterated the fact that conflict
needs to happen with Iran he said that
Iran is cannot be trusted he urged the
European nations to get on board with
the United States the whole thing was a
disaster from beginning to end and and I
just scratched my head wondering why did
did they even put this conference
together it was a PR a foreign policy
disaster and it is Peter well as we said
a self-inflicted wound on Trump the Iran
policy it is a big blotch on the Trump
administration he has started their Iran
policy from the minute he got into
office till now has been one big blunder
he needs to rethink this entire policy
with Iran you know Alex before we let
you go here I mean again it flies in the
face of his campaign promises of not
starting even though I think technically
Iran isn't in the Middle East but I mean
in the greater Middle East not to start
new Wars there and then we have in the
second half of the program were going to
talk about Venezuela it seems a betrayal
of that trust that he ran on 20 seconds
to you go ahead out
yeah I play Peter it's a betrayal of
that trust and we need to understand
this was one of trumps
major major campaign points he was not
going to get the u.s. involved in any
military interventions and he was
actually gonna pull the u.s. out of the
Middle East he needs to keep that
promise otherwise in 2020 he is going to
be in trouble he needs to realize okay
let me jump in here I know you'll be
with us in the future to see if he does
keep his promise sir
I want to thank Alex rue Sephora in
Athens for joining us we're gonna go to
a short break and after that short break
we'll continue our discussion on some
real news stay with our team welcome
back to crosstalk where all things are
considered I'm Peter belt remind you
were discussing some real news
[Music]
okay now we're joined in London by
muckross Papadopoulos he's the editor of
politics first magazine
Marcus great to have you here let's talk
first of all about the the real war and
in terms of sanctions and most
importantly right now the media war
against Venezuela coming out of the West
primarily the United States as we before
we start talking I'd like to point out
to our viewers here the organization
fairness and accuracy in reporting our
fair has a brilliant article titled
Venezuela coverage takes us back to the
Golden Age of lying about Latin America
and I know I sent you the link there I
mean I think it's a brilliant article
and it shows the the sham that's being
portrayed about Venezuela that is
actually inciting not only sanctions and
a media war against it but may ignite
actually a military conflict go ahead
Marcus in London let me first of all
Peter set the scene by saying
historically speaking that the United
States has long had disdain total
disdain for Latin America and Washington
has instigated countless coos in Latin
America and that is what they are
attempting to do today in Venezuela they
America has orchestrated the tension on
the border between Venezuela and
Colombia as a way of giving an pretext
to Washington to take military action
against Venezuela and as always Western
mainstream media or should we just be
more precise corporate media in the
United States and in the UK is peddling
those lies recently Peter the United
Nations rapid war for Human Rights right
visit Venezuela and he traveled quite
extensively of course across Venezuela
Venezuela he compiled a report and he
said clearly and categorically there is
no humanitarian crisis in Venezuela
there is no food
in Venezuela however has any meteor
outlet in the United States or Britain
picked up on that
no has the Guardian newspaper run a
front-page interview with this man no
because what he said does not fit with
the narrative
let me also at this as well Peter in the
1980s in the 1990's Venezuela was ruled
by numerous right-wing governments and
in that time there were millions of
Venezuelans living in abject poverty
untold numbers Peter died because of
starvation and malnutrition
ever since Chavez came to power and been
succeeded by the Maduro millions of
Venezuelans have being all that leaf
pulled up you don't hear about that on
Fox News or CNN or Sky News or Channel 4
News because it doesn't fit been here at
the now it's you know Dima I mean I and
I say to our audience here take a look
at the RT website and gray zone max
Blumenthal has a brilliant brilliant
video of him in a supermarket in Caracas
and I don't want to be a spoiler here
but I mean it just confirms everything
we've just heard from Marcos here where
are we in this coup deema because I've
described the first part this random guy
dough whatever whoever he is okay
because he's not uh he's obviously a
stalking horse for the US and this
so-called Lima group which is obviously
directed against Venezuela and the
current legitimate government there but
it seems to me the first part of this is
the shock and awe well it was a bit
shocking but the AH element is the kind
of receded here we've seen also vivid
footage on the border of these
quote-unquote humanitarian aid I wonder
if that was Elliott Abrams idea because
he's done it before and he lied about it
okay
and he was given unfortunately a
presidential pardon for his crimes that
he committed in the 1980s under the
Reagan administration where are we now
in this code well first of all the
coverage I think there was a brilliant
article on fair org yeah by Mark cook
you know
he just decided to to check the reports
from the time magazine and from other
media outlets in the United States that
there is no aspirin in Venezuela
you know people cannot get treated even
for for a flu you know and he just went
and bought it you know all of these
over-the-counter medicines were
available right so so much for the
fairness of the media and and as Mark
Cook rightly writes in his article you
can you can see from these numerous
stories in the US media they are written
by the people who have never been to
Venezuela you know they just they even
use the same language you know Jonathan
Steele a veteran correspondent for the
Guardian he just counted how many times
that the adjective drab was used for
Venezuela we heard about the drab life
in the Soviet Union about drab
conditions in that in the socialist
Soviet bloc countries so they they just
repeat the same narrative they don't
have to go to Russia all these countries
are the same if they're considered as
enemy as for the strategy of the United
States
strangely Mike Pompeo in in in war so
during that infamous conference that we
have just described when he was talking
about Iran he described the strategy for
Vanessa let me quote him things are now
much worse for the Iranian people and
we're convinced that will lead to the
Iranian people to rise up and change the
behavior of the regime end of quote
so this guy is happy he's glad the
things are worse for the Iranians the
things about these sanctions against
Iran and Venezuela they're not against
the people of course they're against the
people let me go back to Marcus here
Marcus he I think you made a point I
don't think it can be stressed enough
here is that you know you know everyone
knows me as a conservative person okay
and conservative outlook here but there
is no denying that under Chavez millions
and millions of people will pulled out
of poverty and more than that more than
that they were given political agency
they democracy meant something to those
people for the first time in their
entire existence for generations in the
entire history of the Venezuelan State
so Mike Pompeo and John Bolton and
Elliott Abrams
think that people are gonna revolt
against the government that has given
them so much while at the same time not
denying some of the hardships that are
there today go ahead in London well look
Peter one mistakes made by Hugo Chavez
and Nicolas Maduro of course mistakes
were made by both them you tell me Peter
a president's a prime minister who
doesn't make mistakes
however the most important legacy from
the time of Hugo Chavez is that
Venezuela was given back to the
Venezuelan people dignity was restored
to Venezuela Venezuela's state
industries and natural resources were
given back to the Venezuelan people and
it is it is of that first and foremost
that makes people in Washington and
London foam at the mouth including those
wretched journalists journalists and
inverted commas who work for corporate
media and I also add this Peter very
very quickly it's not just the likes of
Trump the Clintons are barmer Bush
Albright and Bolton who should be in an
international court tried for crimes
against humanity
it is the owners and editors of
corporate major outlets who should also
be joining them in the in the dock okay
I want to stay with Marcos here because
you're turning into my Sherpa to
explaining the quagmire I've used that
word a lot than this program these days
call Briggs it what's going on with
Briggs it and what you and I've
disagreed on this topic over the years
that's fine and that's good cuz debate
and difference of opinion is are good
but tell me how this is working out or
not working out in terms of a democracy
deficit because I think for me in my
conservative outlook I'm most concerned
with this deficit here and I'm very
that's one of my gripes with the the EU
in general go ahead my friend explain
what's the the last latest stage of
brexit well I think we disagree when it
comes to a referendum we agree in that
we don't like the European Union and
I've never liked the European Union
what I would say Peter about the brexit
camp and the remain camp both are
instinctively anti-russian and both for
claiming that a referendum or a second
referendum would be would constitute
democracy democracy is not a referendum
democracy involves people electing other
people to represent them at Parliament
that is democracies we agree on that
people we agree on that we agree on that
get away now what's happening well
Britain is supposed to leave the
European Union on the 29th of March I
sincerely hope it happens but we must
embrittle we must have a sensible
negotiated deal with the European Union
one that is approved by British business
British industry and also foreign
investors because Peter if the UK loses
investors at the Chinese the Japanese
and the Indians we will be in serious
trouble
however personalities in the brexit camp
in the remaining camp are dictating
events they don't really care about the
economy so much they can they all they
care about is pursuing their own selfish
ambitions so we help each other amudha
wants to be leader of the Labour Party
we have Jacob Riis Smaug Boris Johnson
who believe they have a god-given right
to be the next prime minister of the
United Kingdom and ordinary people in
Britain the ordinary needs the PP needs
ordinary Britons up and down the UK are
being sidelined because of these awful
personalities you're not gonna get an
argument about the personalities here
let me give the last few words to
Dimitri bar [ __ ] here okay there was
two years hmm they were given a two-year
period did the negotiate this thing here
one has to I will express my opinion and
I think it'll be the history will judge
but it looks like to me this was an
intentional strategy of not having
having a a deal before the brig's had
happened it's
it's a form of scaremongering and it's
it's succeeding here because there will
be there are plenty of people that say
they want another vote they want to
extend the period of but withdrawal if
that's the case then then to resume and
her conservative backers 130 seconds go
to you I think the the stories that
people have been punished for doing a
protest vote in the United States people
voted for Trump because they wanted an
end to the war in Syria and to the war
in Ukraine and to the war in Libya and
and they've been shown now that this is
not going to happen rate the same story
with brexit people voted to get out of
the European Union and now the message
is from the European Union it's my way
or highway it's us okay
okay I'm gonna jump in here I'm gonna
agree with Marcus Papadopoulos because
we've talked about it so many times I'm
not really sure if people really did
know what they were voting for I think
that's the problem here and there's no
major one single no single majority in
parliament how to move forward
we'll be talking about this more many
thanks to my guests in Moscow and in
Athens and in London and thanks to our
viewers for watching us here at RTC see
you next time and remember crosstalk
rules
you